.
THE TERM OCTOBER SURPRISE IS FOR
A REASON.
HERE WITH REACTION FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR ARI FLEISCHER AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP STEPHEN MILLER.
WE WILL START WITH YOU TONIGHT.
CHARGES MADE AGAINST HERSCHEL
WALKER, HE HAS RESPONDED TO
THEM.
OTHER CHARGES HAVE COME OUT IN
THE COURSE OF THE CAMPAIGN.
HE HAS BEEN OPEN ABOUT HIS
PERSONAL STRUGGLES, WROTE ABOUT
THEM EXTENSIVELY.
THAT PART ISN'T A SURPRISE.
ALL'S FAIR IN LOVE, WAR, AND
POLITICS, IT'S A FAIR FIGHT.
BUT THE MEDIA ISN'T TELLING THE
WARNOCK PART OF THE STORY.
THE ACCUSATION OF RUNNING OVER
HIS WIFE, NOT PAYING CHILD CARE.
OBSTRUCTING AN INVESTIGATION
INTO CHILD ABUSE.
THAT WOULD SEEM TO MATTER IF YOU
WANTED TO BE EVENHANDED,
WOULDN'T GET?
>> THEY DIDN'T TELL IT IN 2020
EITHER AND THEY ARE TELLING IT
IN 2022.
IT'S SO EASY TO BE A DEMOCRAT.
WHEN YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT IN THE
PRESS COVERS YOU YOU GET TO
START EVERY INNING WITH A MAN ON
SECOND BASE.
IF YOU'RE REPUBLICAN YOU GET A
START EVERY INNING WITH TWO
STRIKES, IF YOU'RE DONALD TRUMP
YOU START WITH TWO OUTS.
THAT'S THE ADVANTAGE DEMOCRATS
HAVE GOING IN.
THE ADVANTAGE REPUBLICANS HAVE
IS THE POLLS ARE LARGELY WRONG.
REPUBLICANS STOPPED TALKING TO
POLLSTERS, THIS LACK OF TRUST IN
POSTERS AS THEIR IS IN THE
PRESS.
I THINK A LOT OF THESE POLLS YOU
COULD PROBABLY ADD TWO, THREE,
FOUR PERCENTAGE POINTS TO THE
REPUBLICANS SCORE AND THAT'S
PROBABLY A CLOSER READ ON WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THESE ELECTIONS.
>> Sean: STEPHEN MILLER YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE POSITIONS.
BOTH CANDIDATES ONE COULD SAY
HAVE BAGGAGE QUESTIONS BUT
THERE'S A BIG DIFFERENCE IN
TERMS OF WHERE THEY WILL VOTE.
RAPHAEL WARNOCK WANTS COURT
PACKING AND END CASH BAIL.
COMPARED THE POLICE TO GANGSTERS
SAYING THEY HAVE A GANGSTER AND
THUG MENTALITY.
WE KNOW THAT HE WANTS TO MOVE
AWAY FROM ALL FOSSIL FUELS.
HE HAS SAID THAT MANY TIMES.
HE WANTS CRITICAL RACE THEORY
TAUGHT IN SCHOOL.
HE SAID ABOUT THE OPIOID CRISIS
IT'S ONLY A PUBLIC EMERGENCY
BECAUSE THE FACES OF THE HUMAN
TRAGEDY ARE WHITE AND SUBURBAN.
NO RESTRICTIONS ON ABORTION,
INTERESTING CONSIDERING THAT'S A
CONTROVERSY WITH HERSCHEL
WALKER, AND ALL THE OTHER THINGS
WE TALKED ABOUT.
ONE OF THE PEOPLE OF GEORGIA
THINKING TONIGHT AND WHAT SHOULD
BE THINKING TONIGHT?
>> GEORGIA IS A CONSERVATIVE
STATE.
GEORGIA IS A RELIGIOUS STATE,
WHETHER YOU ARE BLACK, WHITE,
BROWN AT IT'S A STATE OF
TRADITIONAL COMMON SENSE VALUES.
RAPHAEL WARNOCK IS AN EXTREMIST
AS YOU LAID OUT A POINT BY
POINT.
ABORTION UP UNTIL THE NINTH
MONTH?
DEFUNDING POLICE AND ALLOWING
VIOLENT CRIMINALS TO LAY WASTE
TO ENTIRE COMMUNITIES,
SUPPORTING BIDENS INFLATIONARY
AGENDA, THAT'S HAMMERING WORKING
FAMILIES.
BEING IN FAVOR OF OPEN BORDERS
AND VOTING FOR OPEN BORDERS TIME
AND TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
SUPPORTING CRITICAL RACE THEORY,
SUPPORTING RADICAL GENDER
IDEOLOGY, 90% OF PEOPLE IN
GEORGIA REJECT HIS VALUES.
THIS IS A RACE ABOUT THE ISSUES
AND IF IT'S FRAMED AS A RACE
ABOUT THE ISSUES THAT HE IS
GOING TO LOSE BY A GIGANTIC
MARGIN.
>> Sean: IS IT A RACE IN THE
MINDS OF PEOPLE IN GEORGIA,
CLAY, IN THIS SENSE THEY ARE
BEING INUNDATED WITH NEVER
ENDING ON ONE CANDIDATE.
THAT'S PART OF THE POLITICAL
PROCESS, EVERYBODY HAS TO ACCEPT
THAT.
YOU JUMP IN THAT ARENA, THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE JUMPING INTO.
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE, THAT'S
WHAT POLITICS IS TODAY.
THE OTHER PART OF IT IS THE
MEDIA CHOOSES TO TELL ONLY THE
STORY OF ONE CANDIDATE BUT NOT
THE OTHER CANDIDATE, THAT'S MY
BEEF.
>> I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT AND I
ACTUALLY THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE WAY THIS IS GOING TO PLAY
OUT, WHO IS WRITING THESE
STORIES?
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" SENT A
WHITE GUY DOWN TO GEORGIA TO
WRITE A FRONT PAGE STORY ON
SUNDAY ABOUT HOW HERSCHEL WALKER
WASN'T BLACK ENOUGH.
A WHITE "NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTER, THEY SENT HIM IN.
"THE DAILY BEAST" IS A HIT
PIECE, THE FIX IS IN.
THE REASON WHY THIS IS HAPPENING
IS BECAUSE GEORGIA IS THE
DEMOCRATIC SENATE FIREWALL.
I WANT ALL GEORGIANS TO LISTEN
TO BE REALLY CAREFULLY RIGHT
NOW.
YOU MAY WELL DECIDE WHETHER
JOE BIDEN CONTROLS THE SENATE OR
NOT.
WHETHER KAMALA HARRIS IS GOING
TO BE ABLE TO BREAK TIES OR NOT
TO.
GEORGIA IN JANUARY OF 2021 DID
NOT MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION
BECAUSE THERE WAS A LOT OF
FALLOUT FROM THIS ELECTION.
YOU KNOW HERSCHEL WALKER, YOU
KNOW JOE BIDEN, THE WORST
PRESIDENT IN OUR NATION'S MODERN
HISTORY 260% OF GEORGIANS DO NOT
LIKE JOE BIDEN.
RAPHAEL WARNOCK IS A
RUBBER-STAMP FOR EVERYTHING
JOE BIDEN WANTS TO DO.
HERSCHEL WALKER IS IMPERFECT AS
ALL FOUR OF US ARE IMPERFECT AS
EVERY SINGLE PERSON WATCHING
THIS IS IMPERFECT BUT HE'S A LOT
BETTER THAN JOE BIDEN AND HE'S A
LOT BETTER THAN RAPHAEL WARNOCK,
YOU CANNOT ALLOW JOE BIDEN TO
GET ANOTHER RUBBER-STAMP, YOU
CAN'T DO IT.
>> Sean: DOES IT MATTER IF
PEOPLE BELIEVE HERSCHEL WALKER
OR NOT?
>> THEY KNOW HIM, THAT'S THE
THING.
YOU'VE LIVED IN GEORGIA, THERE
ISN'T A PERSON IN GEORGIA WHO
DOESN'T ALREADY KNOW HERSCHEL
WALKER AND THAT'S WHY DEMOCRATS
ARE SO DESPERATE RIGHT NOW.
THEY SPENT $50 MILLION RUNNING
THE WORST ADS THAT HAVE EVER
BEEN CREATED TELLING EVERYBODY
HERSCHEL WALKER IS AN AWFUL
HUMAN BEING AND THE VAST
MAJORITY OF GEORGIANS SAID I
JUST DON'T BELIEVE IT.
I HAVE KNOWN THIS GUY SINCE HE
CAME TO PLAY FOR THE
GEORGIA BULLDOGS IN 1980.
I RESPECT THE FACT HE STOOD UP
FOR DONALD TRUMP HIS FRIEND
WHICH IS HOW HE GOT INTO
POLITICS.
DOES HE HAVE ISSUES AND HIS
FAMILY?
YES.
I WAS RAISED A SOUTHERN BAPTIST
AND WHAT WE WERE TAUGHT EARLY ON
IS THAT REDEMPTION IS THERE,
THERE IS ALWAYS THE POSSIBILITY
FOR FORGIVENESS AND THAT IS THE
HEART OF EVERY GEORGIAN.
HERSCHEL WALKER IS GOING TO WIN
THIS RACE AND DEMOCRATS ARE
DESPERATE BECAUSE DEEP DOWN THEY
KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING AND THEY
ARE THROWING EVERY SINGLE THING
THEY HAVE AT HIM.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO END UP
BOUNCING BACK ON TO HIM BECAUSE
THEY KNOW HERSCHEL AND THEY
AREN'T GOING TO BE ABLE TO
CONVINCE GEORGIANS THAT HE'S A
WORSE CHOICE THAN JOE BIDEN'S
RUBBER-STAMP REVEREND RAPHAEL
WARNOCK.
>> Sean: LET'S LOOK AT THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY, 33 DAYS
ELECTION DAY, 41 YEAR HIGH OF
INFLATION IS GOING TO BE ON
EVERY VOTERS MIND.
RECORD HIGH GAS PRICES WILL BE
ON EVERYBODY'S MIND.
THE DISASTER AT THE BORDER WILL
BE ON EVERYBODY'S MIND.
IT SEEMS TO BE EMERGING AS WELL
IS RECORD HIGH CRIME, DEFUND,
DISMANTLE, NO BAIL MENTALITY OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND ALSO
THE ISSUE OF EDUCATION AND
PARENTAL ROLE AS IT RELATES TO
KIDS EDUCATION AND THE VALUES
THAT ARE TAUGHT IN SCHOOL AND
THE FAILURE OF SO MANY SCHOOL
SYSTEMS.
OF ALL THOSE ISSUES, WHAT SHOULD
REPUBLICANS BE TALKING ABOUT THE
MOST?
OR ALL OF THE ABOVE?
>> I THINK CRIME IS CERTAINLY A
BIG ISSUE PARTICULARLY IN THE
SUBURBS, DRUG PROBLEMS ARE
MANIFEST.
EVERYTHING YOU JUST SAID WHAT
SEPARATES THOSE ARE ISSUES LIKE
MEDICARE, ISSUES OF PREVIOUS
DECADES.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT EDUCATION,
YOU TALK OF WHAT WHAT'S BEING
TAUGHT IN SCHOOLS YOU TALK ABOUT
CRIME, THE COST OF BUYING FOOD
FOR THE COST OF FILLING YOUR CAR
WITH GAS.
HEATING YOUR HOUSE OR COOLING
YOUR HOUSE.
EVERY ONE OF THOSE IS A DAILY,
TANGIBLE PROBLEM AND THAT
TRANSCENDS POLITICS, THAT'S WHY
IT'S A POWERFUL REPUBLICAN CYCLE
IN ADDITION TO THE FACT THAT
IT'S A FIRST MIDTERM
HISTORICALLY PRESIDENTS ACHIEVE
THEIR PARTY IN POWER LOSES BIG
NUMBERS OF SEATS IN THEIR FIRST
MIDTERM.
AT ALL OF THAT UP IT'S STILL A
WAVE ELECTION.
REPUBLICANS WILL TAKE THE HOUSE
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT IT,
NANCY PELOSI IS GONE.
I THINK THE SENATE REMAINS A
50/50 SENATE AND IF I'M RIGHT
ABOUT POLLING BEING STILL TILTED
TOWARDS DEMOCRATS IT MEANS IT'S
MUCH MORE LIKELY REPUBLICANS
WILL TAKE THE SENATE WHEN IT ALL
NETS OUT.
I THINK THAT'S THE GREATEST
LIKELIHOOD ON ELECTION DAY FOR A
POWERFUL REPUBLICAN CYCLE.
>> Sean: TALK ABOUT MESSAGING
CANDIDATES TO BE BRINGING INTO
THEIR STATES, THEIR DISTRICTS,
WHAT SHOULD THEY BE TELLING THEM
AND WHAT SHOULD THEY BE
CAMPAIGNING ON?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY THE RIGHT
QUESTION TO BE ASKING.
30 DAYS UNTIL THE SELECTION, HOW
ARE REPUBLICANS GOING TO BRING
THIS THING HOME?
YOU SEE THE MOTOR THEY ARE
SLINGING THAT HERSCHEL WALKER
WHILE COVERING UP RAPHAEL
WARNOCK'S HORRENDOUS PAST.
REPUBLICANS NEED TO LOOK AT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND SAY DO YOU
WANT A SECURE BORDER OR NO
BORDER?
DO YOU WANT TO HAVE NO INFLATION
OR RUNAWAY INFLATION.
DO YOU WANT TO HAVE SAFE STREETS
OR BLOOD-SOAKED CRIME?
DO YOU WANT TO HAVE GREAT
SCHOOLS FOR YOUR CHILDREN OR DO
YOU WANT YOUR KIDS TO BE
INDOCTRINATED, DO YOU WANT YOUR
KIDS TO BE SUBJECTED TO CRITICAL
RACE THEORY AND FORCE GENDER
TRANSITIONS.
YOU FRAME IT AROUND THIS QUALITY
OF LIFE ISSUES YOU FRAME IT
AROUND THESE FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES
OF RIGHT AND WRONG, OF GOOD AND
EVIL AND THIS ELECTION WILL BE
WON BY A HISTORICAL MARGIN.
IT'S UP NOW TO REPUBLICANS TO
PROSECUTE THE CASE AGAINST THE
OVERWHELMING MEDIA BIAS.
>>